please welcome the one and only adam
scott
[Applause]
hey drew hey
hi
oh my god i'm such a fan of yours i'm
freaking out well it's the same same
same right back at you i'm such a big
fan of yours and have been
my whole life essentially i read in some
research is it true
that you have watched sex in the city
and just like that
oh yeah yeah i i watched sex in the city
when it was on originally like we all
did
and then
i got covered
last february you know so i got code the
classic i got the original
covered like pre-vaccine covid
and
was trapped in an apartment by myself in
new york
and just watched
all of sex in the city in like two days
and hadn't seen it in 20 years or
something and it is
incredible it's incredible what they
were doing and so far ahead of their
of their time it's just a it's a
terrific show okay so are you a carrie a
samantha a charlotte or a miranda
i feel like i'm a miranda probably oh my
god i've become a miranda
you have not the end just like that
miranda
sure the sex and the city miranda
um that's the miranda i am as well i
think okay perfect i like the end just
like that miranda and in fact um cynthia
jackson came on the show to talk about
it i love i liked and just like that
because at first i was like i want my
old sex in the city and then i was like
what am i talking about we're all older
and we're not the same they're moving on
i need you too and then i got on board
yeah
me too and i also felt a little
protective of it and that people were
really quick to jump all over a show
starring all these women in their 50s i
feel like we should applaud
that and applaud
them you know putting
these women
on a show together it's great okay
now your amazing wife is it true
that when your wife first met you
she was like
oh no no no no you're an actor
yeah i mean it's only she's smart so of
course she would be a little
trepidatious
dating an actor
and also one that kind of wasn't like i
wasn't
i didn't really have anything to show
for it really i was just
trying to jump from guest spot to guest
spot and
had a little apartment like i don't know
why she dated me but um i'm really glad
she did
did she ever say like oh actors are
typically
dot dot dot
and that would be my fear did she give
you any reasons other than just being an
actor yeah
i think
kind of you know full of themselves and
uh
and full pro i think full of themselves
i think she's right like i think actors
are
really kind of self-involved to be cut
but for good reason because the thing
we're doing and the thing that we're
selling is us so it's hard not to be
self involved to a certain degree
as an actor but
um
but so i was working pretty hard to show
her that i wasn't uh self-involved to
prove her prove her wrong you know we
were we were just shooting the other
night we're shooting party down and we
were sitting there excited about
yeah you just finished shooting party
down is coming back it's like
the cult classic everybody freaks out
this is so exciting okay sorry not to i
didn't mean to direct no no no not at
all we were just shooting on saturday
night we just finished and jennifer
garner's on the show now and she and i
were sitting there
and someone was getting us coffee and
asking us if we wanted a snack and and
we just realized we're like babies like
actors are like
like toddlers and everything on sets at
least is sort of done for them so it is
ridiculous how pampered uh uh actors are
it can be true
but
look at you and and i'm sure your wife
is so happy that she gave you a chance
and you seem like such a good person
oh thanks drew well i i'm so so glad she
uh she gave me a chance as well i'm very
lucky
[Music]